this September Volkswagen is planning an
initial public offering for luxury
sports car maker Porsche the IPO is
targeting a 75 billion valuation for
Porsche which would make it Germany's
second largest IPO in history Volkswagen
is expected to price preferred shares of
Porsche AG between 76 Euros 50 cents and
82 Euros 50 cents per share if the upper
range of the proposed price is achieved
it would make Porsche's IPO the third
largest on record in Europe as part of
the listing Porsche's Shares are being
split in two with 455.5 million ordinary
shares and 455.5 million preferred
shares or 911 million shares overall a
number of car enthusiasts will instantly
recognize as Porsche's most iconic model
as part of the deal VW plans to sell 25
plus one ordinary share in Porsche AG to
Porsche SE the holding firm controlled
by the founding Porsche piak family this
will allow the family to retain a
minority stake in the company and have a
say in future company decisions
the Porsche PX family has also agreed to
pay a 7.5 premium on top of the price
range for the preferred shares
other parties with planned stakes in
Porsche include the Sovereign wealth
funds of Qatar Abu Dhabi and Norway as
well as the mutual fund company T Rowe
Price
with the expected 9.4 billion dollars it
raises from the IPO Volkswagen will
finance a shift to electric vehicles and
future investments in software
development
Porsche Shares are expected to begin
trading on the Frankfurt Stock Exchange
on September 29th
foreign